they are called solar explosions we're
talking about ejections from the Sun
that head out into the solar system
objections that could one day fri the
earth's electrical grids all right but
now a satellite it's called the
deep-space climate Observatory is headed
toward the Sun to serve as an early
warning system and you know one of the
things that attracted my attention to
this story scarlet is because we have
become so dependent on the functions of
satellites that anything that would
disrupt either the electrical grid or
communications to satellites or global
positioning services that are used in
everything from uber to any kind of
delivery mechanism modern life
essentially yeah could be affected by
these eruptions from the Sun we've known
about them for a long time these clouds
of magnetic material can travel as much
as 3,000 miles a second and the issue
has always been to identify them with a
kind of early warning system and it
turns out that Neil Saverin he's a
researcher at the Goddard Space Center
down in Greenbelt Maryland he's decided
that maybe what you need to do is take
various points on the Sun take all that
information collect it and then be able
to present the picture that could offer
an early warning system as much as 24
hours in advance so you could prepare
the grid you can prepare your system
because you don't want to be left
without electricity or access to let's
say GPS how precise of a warning system
can this be though will it just kind of
give you 0 over the east coast or 0 over
the Americas yeah it could be it could
be precise and the issue has to do with
the way the magnetic material is
positioned visa V the earth so for
example if you are going south to north
with the magnetic material no problem
right but if you're going north to south
you could have a big problem so it's not
just the size of the magnetic eruption
but it's also the direction